- Le ton est donné pour
législatives en France.
C'est à cette étape qu'on saura
si la coalition Ensemble
du président Emmanuel Macronueue
à l'Assemblée nationale.
pour mener sa politique
de réformes, dont celle
des retraites.SASASASASASASASAS,
première ministre de la France
- usus sommes la seule force
en mesure d'obtenir la majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Face à la situation
du monde et à la guerre
aux portes de l'Europe,
nous ne pouvons pas prendre
et des approximations.
- Aussitôt les résultats
préliminaires annoncés,
celui qui talonne la coalition
le parti d'Emmanuel Macron
a été battu et défait.enenenener
un appel aux électeurs.
JEAN-LUC MÉLENCHON, c
La France insoumise - NUPES
- Pour la première fois
de la 9e République,eneneneneneu
ne parvient pas à réunir
une majorité à lctctction
législative qui suit.
Pour nos vies personnelles et
pour le destin n n n n n n n n e
à déferler dimanche prochain.
- Ces élections législatives ont
mis en lumière l'effondrement
de la droite traditionnelle
tititititititititititititititite
de Marine Le Pen, qui arrive
sisisisième avec 18 % des voix.
MARINE LE PEN, cheffe de groupe
Rassemblement National
laisser Emmanuel Macron
disposer d'une majorité absolue
dont il abusera pour appliquer
ses méthodes autocentrées
et brutales.
de droite ou de gauche,
une question demeure :
seront-ils plus nombreux
au deuxième tour? Un Français
sur deux a boudéd.d.d.d.d.d.d.d.
- Je trouve ça vraiment
dommage qut t t t t un taux
d'abstention aussi élevé.
Parce que, lors des
présfofofofofofofofofofofofofof.
J'avais fait la queue une heure
à la mairie et, là,
il y avait personne.
- Je ne sais passtststststststse
c'est un devoir d'aller voter.
- Le second tour aura lieu
dimanche prochaiucucucucucucucuc
Mélenchon devait l'emporter,
elle impose e e e e cohabitation
inédite avec le président
Macron, fraîchement réélu.jejeje
pour le locataire de l'Élysée :
ululululultat final pourraitouoe
15 ministres, dont la premièreÉ,
sont candidats.
En cas de défaite,
ils devront démissionner.
Chantal Leblond